belle a tutti ragazzi venuti avessimo
video sono pa vj oggi siamo su un altro
videogioco con l'oculista che credo che
nessuno sappia che cos'è ormai questo
cosa seriamente ho fatto talmente tanta
roba che credo che sostituirà gli
occhiali quando sarò vecchio con questo
ci andrà in giro proprio così i ragazzi
aspettava l'uscita di sto gioco da un
casino di tempo per loculo state quindi
sono proprio curioso di vedere che
diavolo proviamo poi piuttosto muoio
perfetto ragazzi ci siamo allora warning
this game news jumps carsen flash la è
grazie al cazzo visto un play out
problems o mio dio ragazzi sto per
morire previsto senza per continuare
perfetto e la madonna windows 8
ascolta zio ma ti gira a battlefield suo
computer per caso comunque a parte sa
può solo se funziona internet un
qualcosa in stacco se mi posso abbassare
di scatto così mica sono un fenomeno di
squat proprio
comunque ragazzi a parte la madonna che
la grafica di bella che abbia mai visto
sul colosseo fino adesso
madonna è più ordinata di candela mia
sta cosa a parte gli scherzi peso
l'altezza non solo a guardare al nostro
caso di armadi comunque ragazzi e per
testare qualche a [ __ ] che è la madonna
che tre devo sapermi miss ed è una
figata dalla grafica voglio capire se ci
sono anche spaventi spero di no find a
chi trova la chiave per cazzola trova la
chiave questo bisogno di palma dove
dovrei messo le chiavi della macchina
che devo uscire di casa è la madonna
dylan dog e addirittura no no grazie io
leggo solo topolino perché sono un
bambino ecco la chiave per non è vero
anche mio padre che ha 80 anni legge
topolino non hai 80 scusa papa comunque
a parte sta roba e ho trovato la chiave
per aprire la porta e se riesco a uscire
grazie madonna mia madre mente sempre
cose di amal e soprattutto armadietto
giorno ma c'è una torcia ma perché non
vedo dalla in poi non vedo più un cazzo
me le posso style estinto argomento
armano mamma ma mai chiuso la porta
va bene è ragazzi mi si è chiusa la
porta alle spalle potrebbe essere un
problema
matelica si sente un pianoforte di
sottofondo che c'è qualcuno che sa find
the safe urumqi cina verga mi ha dato
una chiave io devo andare avanti non ha
una grafica per ragazzi sembra di essere
veramente intendendo così ma si torna a
giocare al computer no e ragazzi il
cazzo aperto la porta
no no no mamma mi su chi pensi va aveva
pagate le bollette qui e che cazzo se
certo devo vedere che cazzo se stavolta
prima che faccia buio non ossa riuscito
via via vela perfetto via via via grazie
chiudiamo chiudiamo non si che non
canterà che allora già il posto faceva
schifo se vogliamo andare anche sotto
mica che bei posti malaman marco quando
vado in cantina a casa mia è così bella
eppure allagato grazie al trend però
vabbè dai seriamente è la madonna
ragazzi portati il costume da bagno che
facciamo in parti bardi in casa ma
seriamente se sapevo veramente portavo
il bagnoschiuma anche cazzo estero come
ci sono arrivato io qua qual è
l'obiettivo di sto gioco
vedo la luce in fondo al tunnel ma non
sono ancora morto credo ho già capito
che alla fine del tunnel non ci arrivo
in un modo o nell'altro può essere sopra
l'acqua ragazzi questo è sotto cioè
uguale per dire io non vedo solo dove
sono messo brega c'è un tipo di via via
via via numero di app e april buon uomo
mi apre la porta grazie e buon nuovo
grazie non è un buon uomo secondo gatti
è scattato un [ __ ] allarme c'era un
tizio non so cosa devo fare ma corro
come se non ci fosse un domani grazie è
stato bello
salve buongiorno a chi è bel ragazzo ha
né nudo o mio dio ma sento davvero ma
con la madonna che se sta bene e sta è
stato bello conoscerti inserimento e
dato ragazzi ma guardate che bello
mentre ondeggia
gli ho detto di presentarvi in costume
da bagno e non completamente nudi
comunque diamo suo promesso posso
entrare nelle grazie con una lentezza
che fa veramente schifo dato tutti i
posti alle grigie un'imbiancata lari
darei asti muri avrò fatto il caso che
vole tanto e casa volta c'è una sedia
che cazzo ci fa una sedia mi ascolti
signora sedia molto gentile lei che sta
qualche bella che tra l'altro bellico
più comoda della mia di sicuro sentite
ci sono delle sedie violentate a terra
proposto possibilmente si può uscire di
qua grazie a si è aperta mica non
pensavo non è stato semplice
sento il rumore di un lavandino aperto
ma che bello trovato una chiave a caso
non ne faccio posso moderni jules alla
fine vi prego fatemi buttare giù dalla
finestra del tragico se non ci stiamo
avvicinando alla porta che bello
permesso posso entrare qua dentro almeno
adesso che grazie molto gentile
buongiorno c'è un altro nudo allora
ragazzi oggi aveva invitato in piscina
prima ma dovete portare ai costumi non è
una piscina per nudisti tanto e
soprattutto la faccia un po forte si è
fatto male zio ecco l'esatta mia
reazione dopo aver fatto i compiti di
matematica uguale mica se si girolami
cagato addosso ma ok
oddio strategia sbagliata dei tratti
rossetto non si mette lì e rossetto
voglio dire attivati guardare un film
insieme da guardiamo sta roba bellissimo
cos'è bering ritorno 6 from chi
prendiamo la sua chiave caccia femmina
sono amici tuoi avevo detto di non
invitare nessuno a casa chi cazzo è
questo perché c'è un tizio che corre
sulla telecamera a caso ragazzi ma mai
bene dal tipo nudo di prima ragazzi sta
venendo qui bene guarda zioni ti capisco
che non sei riuscito a fare matematica
lo so come ti permetti di zitti smi che
questa è casa mia mi gratifica uno
schiaffo che voi ragazzi siete
fantastici sono che dovrei uscire grazie
dell'ospitalità molto gentili c'è anche
un bel culo io esco graziani ha via via
via via via via sono uscito c'è il tipo
di prima sta venendo qua cristo santo
che cazzo ci fa ragazzi c'è un tipo che
sta avvenendo tico a buongiorno ascolta
guana tinti volevo prendere per il culo
prima
stai correndo via via via via vivi
ancora cristo è dio
buongiorno ma che figo che sei fatto si
muove al rallenty quella mano zio ben e
ho distrutto tutto ma ripartiamo che è
stato figo poi luridi stronzi comunque
ragazzi mi è mai successo non si può
correre come faccio quando si è messo a
correre mi è passata la vita davanti che
si può fare quando ti paghi del genere
dylan dog con mezzi o che sta qua a
terra non so se hai voglia non c'ha
voglia se ne sta andando sta camminando
l'ho capito se n'è andato non ha visto
adesso credo jackson ha visto via via
via via via via via in un correggo ad
ostra velocità io perfetto contorno
ascolta sia lo so che viene al rallenty
verso di me perché mi ami però
[Musica]
ma visto che botta di culo incredibile
non ha visto bene dove cazzo vado a via
via via via via.b a 66 from era quella
l'inizio
allora so dove andare vai vai veloce
luce un cazzo se un passato io si è
spenta la luce bello comunque la
prossima volta che invito qualcuno in
piscina che si porti il costume vi prego
almeno quello dove doveva buona
educazione
che bello siamo tra due ore per tornare
mica se sapevo sfondato la porta a
calcio e facevo privata d'asta frate
scanu dei fogli e tipo sarà la sana
stampanti 6 from sarà sicura sarà
assicurata sta minkia sono convinto ciao
belli ma che bel disegno cota c'è una
torcia dio ti ringrazio veramente non ci
credo c'è allora ha via via via vi prego
vi prego vi prego dimmi che non apre la
porta di che non apre la porta madonna
punto sei brutto non sai neanche tool
per ragazzi c'è una o mio dio santo non
aprite quella porta nel vero senso della
della porta i ragazzi a parte sto tizio
nudo che sta fuori che cosa potrei fare
per uscire secondo me devo guardare
c'entra qualcosa sto disegno ma non so
cosa ho preso la torcia e si è spento
tutto quindi era meglio prima con una
pistola ma sei serio lo prende a
recuperano seriamente come faccio a
prenderla
ho preso una pistola ma non posso
sparare cioè potrebbe essere inutile
ascolta zio obiettivo è di fare una gara
a chi spara meglio vabbè io so cos'è la
bibbia c'è la bibbia sul pianoforte
bello ho preso delle robe però non ho
capito che è uscito se n'è andato ma sto
cazzo che esco io rimango qua a morire
no seriamente regalo ho preso tutte le
donne gente è finito è finito così cioè
devo prendere una pistola bibbia e una
storia ed è fini che cazzo è servita la
torcia che problemi avete voi che avete
creato sto gioco qualcomm che ragazzi
concluso che l'episodio spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto è piaciuto un po
meno i miei capelli però dopo steam
parti sarebbe strano se avessi dei
capelli normali e per chi ti dice
ultimamente tipo farli ma non stai
facendo il giochino dove prendi spaventi
[ __ ] nonché ragazzi conclude
episodio perché devo prendere delle
aspirine dopo questa roba
sei video è piaciuto consente lasciato
come
mi piace fatemi sapere se volete che
giochi al gioco quello completo quando
uscirà spero per voi ovviamente che
diciate di no tanto vi vengo a cercare a
casa altrimenti vi auguro un uomo nudo
alto due metri fuori dalla porta di casa
senese vorresti stimati nel civ il
diavolo fosse una bella ragazza